today on the matt walsh show big tech is
in the middle of a massive purge of
conservative it's worse now than it's
ever been before
and the new democrat administration
hasn't even officially taken over yet so
how bad is it going to get also five
headlines including
aoc claiming that half of congress
nearly died when the capital was stormed
on wednesday and our daily cancellation
we have an example
we have a real example of actual
systemic racism
we can see what it's really like what it
really looks like courtesy of joe biden
all of that and more today on the matt
walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
well before we get going today i want to
tell you about our good friends over at
charity mobile you know with everything
happening in the world today especially
now
uh it's never been more important for us
to
find the companies that support us as
conservatives
and and uh support our values and to
support them you know
because it's it's a sort of a mutual
relationship here and that's what
charity mobile is um
one company that fits the description as
a company that supports our values is
charity mobile because they're the
pro-life phone company
and the reason that the pro-life phone
company is that five percent of your
monthly plan price with charity mobile
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
and that's the financial piece of it and
that's really important because that's a
lot of money that's going
to the fight for life and the culture
what that also just tells you is that is
that this is a
company whose values line up with our
own and you can feel proud
to you know be a customer of a company
like that
um a lot of other perks as well new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping
uh there are no contracts there's no
termination fees there's a
30-day guarantee so there's no risk
either and if you have any issues
whatsoever they've got live
customer service based right here in the
usa which is great also
and uh you know you want to be able to
protect your kids if they have a cell
phone
so you've got the ability to block the
use of cellular data picture messages
text messages on any or all of your
accounts you have that kind of control
over it
they're going to give you a free app to
monitor your usage pay your bills and
whatever else you need to do
makes it a lot easier and all the while
you're helping to build a culture of
life in america while supporting a
pro-life phone company at the same time
here's what you need to do call charity
mobile at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with
them
online at charitymobile.com you may
remember back in 2012 two gay men
visited a small bakery in lakewood
colorado asking for a cake for their
upcoming
wedding ceremony the owner of the shop
jack phillips politely informed them
that
he couldn't provide a custom wedding
cake for a gay wedding due to his
christian beliefs but he offered to sell
them
any other bait good in stock the couple
left they didn't want anything else and
they promptly filed a human rights
complaint with the colorado civil rights
commission
which sided with the gay men and ordered
phillips to bake the cake
pay the fine and attend mandatory
anti-discrimination training for himself
and all of his staff
phillips appealed the decision and the
ensuing six years were a nightmare of
litigation fines and court cases for him
culminating
in arguments presented to the supreme
court but even after the supreme court
sided with phillips and chastised the
civil rights commission for its
overreach
still the lgbt lobby would not leave the
matter alone a few years later phillips
was in court yet again for
declining to make another cake this time
a cake meant to honor a man's
transition into a woman a request made
by a trans activist who was clearly
looking for an excuse to sue by the way
and found it
now through all this the media the
democrat party and the left generally
have
been nearly unanimous in their position
that jack phillips is guilty of
unspeakable human rights violations
and that he should not have the right to
refuse service to anyone on account of
his own personal convictions
they've argued stridently for years that
allowing a man like phillips to decline
to make a custom
wedding cake for a gay wedding even
though he was willing again to sell them
any pre-made item in the story wasn't he
wasn't he wasn't turning them down
he wasn't refusing them service he just
said this one particular service i can't
give you for this act for this
particular event
but they said that that would lead to
the alienation and ostracization of
certain groups of people and that such
an outcome is untenable
in society the same things have been
said about florists who don't want to
provide flowers for gay weddings and
t-shirt companies that don't want to
make t-shirts for gay pride parades
etc in all of these cases the left has
absolutely rejected the freedom of
association
and free enterprise arguments and
insisted that for the sake of the
greater good
business owners sometimes have to be
forced to provide services
they don't want to provide now this is
all important background when we
consider recent actions by the most
powerful big tech companies in the world
using the ride on capitol hill as an
excuse to do something that they were
almost certainly going to do anyway
twitter last week as i'm sure you heard
permanently banned donald trump that is
the sitting president of the united
states
banned him from their platforms facebook
snapchat instagram
all announced similar measures reddit
got into the act
banned the subreddit dedicated to trump
that's out too
at the same time twitter embarked on
what appears to be a massive
purge of conservative accounts as
conservatives
with with large followings experienced
significant drops in their follower
accounts
um starting last week and going into
this week i lost around
25 000 followers in the span of two days
which
doesn't come close to winning the prize
for the steepest fall
and the point isn't that we're upset
that we lost followers the point is
that that represents 25 000 accounts for
me anyway that were wiped out
so this is not the first time that these
companies have
teamed up to purge and punish the
cultural heretics
usually when these things happen those
on the left will
sneer that you know we conservatives
should just suck it up and
make our own social media sites though
so that we can engage in wrong think
out of view and away from polite society
as it happens some conservatives have
done exactly that with sites like parlor
and parlor at first experienced a
dramatic surge in traffic this past week
as conservative refugees
from other sites poured in and set up
accounts on on their platform
but then the next shoe drops amazon
apple and google announced that they're
going to be banning parlor from their
servers and app stores
parlor ceo john matsey said that all of
the site's vendors
every single one including text message
services email providers
even their lawyers abandoned them all at
once
on the same day all at one time
and now parlor's down if you try to go
there now it's down and it's going to be
down for the foreseeable future
will it ever be up again we don't know
they have to figure out a way to exist
on the internet
while being blacklisted by apple amazon
and google
that is a very difficult if not
impossible thing to pull off
especially if you don't have massive
financial resources
the stated reason for this move against
parlor is that
somehow in an unspecified way parlor is
violating
unclear rules again against violence and
illegal
activity and incitement and obscene
content
but it goes without saying that none of
these companies have ever cracked down
ever on users who celebrated or
encouraged the blm riots
nor have apple google or amazon punished
any social media sites that play host to
such content
and as for illegal activity i mean come
on
you can find plenty of that on apps that
are still available on these platforms
many murders and rapes have been linked
to hookup apps like grinder and tinder
and yet again there has been no
crackdown on such a large scale or even
on a smaller scale
the reasons given do not hold up to the
slightest scrutiny the truth then is
painfully obvious
the wealthiest and most powerful
companies in the world
have engaged in a coordinated campaign
to silence ideologically dissenting
voices
and drive them from the public square
that's what's happening
the people who sit by and watch this
approvingly applauding the purge
calling for more of it are the exact
same people who have issued
many ominous warnings about the dire
consequences
of allowing a small bakery in colorado
to decline to make a customized cake for
for a gay wedding somehow they argue gay
couples
who might have to drive a mile down to
the road to a different cake shop in the
same town to get a customized patriot or
being saddled with a
a customized pastry are being saddled
with a traumatizing burden
and if we don't impose harsh legal
penalties on the bakery
that refuse them we risk the eventual
exclusion of all gay people from modern
society that's what they say
yet they continue there is no such risk
and no imaginable problem with allowing
multi-billion dollar tech companies
to collaborate with each other to expel
politically inconvenient voices
and relegate them permanently to the
backwaters and ghettos of the internet
they do not believe that the small town
bakery has
any claim to freedom of association or
free enterprise
but they will happily afford those
considerations
to the billion-dollar conglomerates who
control almost every aspect of our lives
and these are also the people who
usually tell us about the evil
corporations and how terrible they are
this is all of course completely
backwards
and it could only be so backwards
because the people who hold this
backwards view
are not worried about intellectual
consistency and are not bothered by
their own lack of integrity
and they don't care if you notice it
either
in reality there is no significant
downside no serious consequence
to a small business owner in middle
middle america somewhere
choosing not to provide a service for a
ceremony he opposes for religious
reasons
at most on the part of the spurned
customer
it amounts to mildly hurt feelings and a
minor inconvenience
as they again just have to get in the
car just drive right down the street to
a different bakery
same exact thing the cake will be just
as good
there are however cataclysmic downsides
and outright dystopian consequences to
allowing
the companies that essentially control
the entire internet
to engage in coordinated ideological
discrimination on this scale
and the other difference between these
two situations is that a bakery
is merely a bakery it's a small private
business and nothing more
but what about facebook and twitter what
what are they
we don't even know are they platforms
are they publishers are they utilities
are they all of those things
the answer to that question determines
whether they have the right to do what
they're doing
and if they do currently have the legal
right the next question is whether they
ought to have that right
and whether laws should be changed so
that they don't have it
i cannot see how any rational and honest
person could possibly argue
that the bakery doesn't and shouldn't
have the right to decline
one form of service to one customer yet
the big tech monopolies do and should
have the right
to ban millions from all of their
services
effectively muting their voices in the
public sphere and excluding them from
the national conversation
that doesn't make any sense now there is
a purist
libertarian argument that defends both
the big tech monopoly and the bakery on
an equal basis
but that's not the argument that most of
the people defending big tech in this
case are making
and also i think it's a bad argument
anyway big tech is in a class by itself
because of the stranglehold it has on
all of our lives whether we like it or
not
the question is not whether they should
be allowed to inconvenience
us or bruise our egos or hurt our
feelings
it's whether they should be allowed to
control us censor us
and rule us the bakery is
not going to rule over us the bakery has
no control over our lives
at all utterly powerless
that's not the case for big tech and
the answer to whether or not they should
be allowed to control us censors and
rule us is no they should not
they should be reined in they should be
held to
basic standards of ethics fairness and
transparency but unfortunately
the next part of the answer is that
though they shouldn't be allowed to do
what they're doing
they have been allowed to do it and
trump and the gop didn't do
anything to prevent it when they had the
power to prevent it
so this is where we are now and it's not
going to stop
the left cannot win based solely on its
ideas
it cannot win through argument or
advocacy they know it
and that's why they're done with arguing
against your ideas
instead it's very simple for them
they'll just ensure that your ideas are
not heard
in the first place now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
uh you know big big football weekend by
the way in more
more positive news and lighter news big
football week i feel kind of bad
being happy
this morning after the titans lost
because i you know we just moved to
nashville so i'm a tennessee resident
now
but i'm also a big ravens fan so big big
matchup between the titans and ravens
yesterday ravens win i feel great about
it the rest of the town they're all in
mourning in tears
and i'm just skipping merrily i skipped
to work today merrily
whistling and singing that's how happy i
was and it's it's it's bad
too because it's uh you know these are
two teams that don't like each other and
at the end of the game the ravens uh
marcus peters got an interception to
seal the deal
then they went to the middle of the
they're playing in nashville they went
to the middle of the stadium
on the tennessee titans logo and just
started dancing and stomping on it
which in fairness the the titans did it
first because titans played the ravens
in baltimore earlier in the season did
the exact same thing
now usually i wouldn't accept that
excuse for my kids
they did it first but in this case i
accept it because i'm a ravens fan and i
kind of love seeing it
also it's football and that's just the
way these things should go you know i
don't believe in
the teams they're shaking hands and they
pretend to be friends no you should hate
each other when you're on the football
field
that's how i feel uh that was great we
have more on on
on football weekend and uh coming up
a little bit later in the five headlines
but let's start with this alexandria
ocasio-cortez was
on abc this weekend and um
made some rather dubious claims about
the capitol hill riots
and the the uh the danger that she says
she was in let's let's take a listen to
this
republican members of congress who
opposed uh raising objections to the
certifying the electoral college vote
have written a letter
to president-elect biden opposing
impeachment here's what the letter says
it says in the spirit of healing
and fidelity to our constitution we ask
you fully request that speaker nancy
pelosi discontinue our efforts to
impeach
president donald j trump a second time a
second impeachment only days before
president trump will leave office
is as unnecessary as it is inflammatory
they're saying for the sake of unity
for go impeachment
well you know i think there's a couple
of things one is we have to understand
that what happened on wednesday
was insurrection against the united
states
that is what that is what donald j trump
engaged in and that is what those who
stormed the capital engaged in
and so when we talk about healing the
process of healing
is separate and in fact requires
accountability
and so if we allow insurrection against
the united states
with impunity with no accountability
we are inviting it to happen again
that is how serious it is and i do not
believe
that that perhaps my colleagues weren't
in that room
perhaps my colleagues were not
fully present for the events on
wednesday but
half of we came close to half of the
house nearly dying
on wednesday oh you did half of the
house nearly dying
half really that's what we came close to
and she she hasn't no the phoniness here
of course is off the charts
across the board with everything she
said um and the idea that that
half of the house almost died is is she
has no basis for saying that but
then again this is the one to remember
if you're if you're you shouldn't be
surprised to see
drama and hyperbole from alexandria
cortez this is the woman who went down
to the border and if you remember a
couple years ago
uh took took pictures of herself
pretending to cry
outside of a uh immigrant detention
center actually she wasn't even outside
of the detention center she was outside
of a parking lot
she took pictures of herself outside of
an empty parking lot posing as if she
was in tears
so keep that in mind that's that's who
this is coming from
but everything else about this was
insurrection insurrection
even if it was okay uh i'm not even
arguing about
what label we put on it whether it was
or wasn't
i don't believe for a second that
alexandria case or cortez or any of the
other democrats actually care about
insurrection
in principle because they certainly
didn't care
leftist radicals set up their own
country in the middle of a of an
american city
for months and were allowed to do it
and we all just went about our day and
said okay well that's something you can
do now apparently
they set up their own sovereign country
said they were seceding from the union
had their own country in the middle of
the city is that that insurrection
or as i pointed out many times last week
invading a police station and burning it
to the ground
it's a government building that's an
attack on law enforcement
is that insurrection she didn't care
about that
and speaking of pretending to care about
things
it has it has it's very difficult for me
to hear
people like this or democrats generally
as they have been in the media
um over the last several days has
pretended has
been pretending to mourn the death of
officer sicknick who's
the officer who died during the uh
during the capitol hill riot now
i mourn for for the officer and for his
family
and i'm devastated that he died i'm
infuriated by by his loss
it's also it's also not yet clear it's
not exactly
clear yet how he died there's a lot of
information we haven't been given
and as far as i know the the the images
of of his interactions with the crowd
whatever happened incident we haven't
seen any image of we haven't seen any
video we haven't seen any photograph as
far as i know and i've looked
um maybe there isn't any image but that
would be hard to believe these days
so it's not exactly clear what happened
but or how it happened they haven't
given us all the information yet
but however it happened it's a terrible
tragedy because we know that an officer
died
yet now you have democrats in the media
talking about officer siknik and how
terrible it is and what a tragedy it is
and it is terrible it is a tragedy
i just don't believe that they give the
slightest
damn about him and the reason for that
is that this is the only dead cop
that these people have ever mourned ever
prove me wrong find me another example
because there unfortunately have been a
lot of dead police officers
through through history and especially
this past year
a lot of police officers were physically
assaulted police officers were
beat over the head with bricks during
blm riots
we got we got video in new york police
officers are getting beat over the head
with a brick
the only reason he didn't die he didn't
die thank god it's not for lack of
trying though
we don't give blm credit because well
they tried to kill a bunch of cops
but they failed you don't get credit for
that
it's it is it is the rest of society's
great fortune that he's still alive
but you tried to kill him but anyway do
you remember did alexandria
did any democrat when that video came
out in new york of the cop getting beat
over the head
with a brick how many democrats how many
people in the media condemned it
did any of them
so i don't believe it they don't really
care
you know pretending to be upset that uh
the flag wasn't put at half-mast outside
the white house right away
once again i think the flag should be at
half-mast and now it is i think it
should have been a half-mast right away
do they actually give a damn though
about that
no they don't absolutely full of it
um speaking of being full of it number
two big news from colin powell
he is uh leaving the republican party
again i think this is his fifth time
leaving he's gone for the guinness
record which is eight i believe
i gotta check again but here's colin
powell leaving the republican party
again
and that's why i can no longer call
myself a fellow republican
you know i'm not a fellow of anything
right now i'm just a citizen who has
voted republican voted democrat
throughout my entire career
i would hope that the republican party
as they're moving away from this fellow
who's no longer the president
i hope they would not let him back into
the camp so he can demonstrate
or say that oh i'm still here i'm going
to do it all no you're not you're out
and act like you're out okay yeah so
another another time
this was i this was news the first time
you did it back in like 2008 or seven or
eight or whatever it was
but colin powell's this guy now he's one
he's one of many guys that um
that the the media has on tap or they
they just bring him in
every few months to leave the republican
party if they need a guy to leave the
republican party they just bring colin
powell in again
just one of those guys that they have do
that and we've seen this a lot over the
last four years
um people performatively denouncing and
leaving the republican party
over and over again i mean it's one
thing to do at once if you're leaving
you're leaving fine
but to keep on doing it
and and uh at a certain point it's like
well you've already left so what does
this mean
it's kind of like it's in the same vein
as when the left
boycotts a company that they would never
use in the first place
a store they never go to they boycott
like a hardware store a little boycott a
hardware store
they don't even know what a screwdriver
looks like except the kind that you you
know get at a bar
um so that's that's the the first thing
and the other thing is let's pretend
this was colin powell's first
time that he's leaving the republican
party or anybody else
you know people in the administration
who are resigning in protest
or some of the people that have come out
in the last week and said i'm done with
this
um that that's not really worth anything
because whatever you think of trump and
how he's acted
he's he's been trump the whole time
right so this is this is this is who
trump's been
and if you're just deciding right now
when it happens to be the end of his
administration
that now you're going to come out and
make your big stand
um yeah i'm not very impressed i have to
say
talk about it it is like the emptiest of
empty gestures
imaginable all right number three brian
stelter on cnn
wants you to know that the big tech
purge
is really no big deal no big deal at all
don't worry about it here's
brian stelter's argument but it doesn't
get much more shameful
than this white house aides talking
about a narrative
shift trump advisor saying they want
people to talk about big technology
and not the riot you know what i have
had enough
of this talk that they can try to change
the narrative that they can try to
divert attention
how about focusing on the funerals how
about focusing on the fact that this
president
hasn't even had the flags and washington
lowered to half staff
in respect for the capitol police
officer who was killed
who was attacked how about that how
about some focus on that
you know i think what's clear victor and
christy in the last couple days we've
seen more and more videos of the riot
from different angles
visuals that we didn't see live on
wednesday it's become more and more
clear this attack was even more violent
than we saw
live on tv this was even more
treacherous trump's behavior was even
more disturbing than we knew in real
time
we were minutes away from a possible
massacre
of lawmakers in our country in our in
our seat of government
and and i you know i actually think as
the days go on and people process this
trauma
and we see more and more of these videos
this story becomes bigger and it becomes
worse
so good luck mr president talk about big
technology
i'm sure that his super fans the most
loyal of his fans
will go along with that petty attempt at
a diversion
but i think the vast majority of
americans will see through it
how do people watch this guy on purpose
every time i see a clip like this i can
barely get through it
imagine there i i guess there are people
who sit down on their couch like on us i
don't know when this show
airs but on a saturday and they say i'm
going to spend
an hour watching this guy my god
no i mean we know that that 90 percent
of cnn
cnn's audience are people in you know
dentist waiting rooms and airports so
maybe that accounts for all of it but i
just can't imagine it
or understand why but any case he's
worried about uh
changing the narrative we're distracting
from the real story yeah we know
we know brian stelter and cnn they're
really worried about that
these these are the people we recall who
you know
spent um months and months telling us
about the coronavirus and how it's the
worst plague in history and we're all
going to die and then
and then at the drop of a hat they just
dropped that
and uh were cheering on mass rioting
for months on end and then when the mass
rioting ended they picked right back up
with the chronovirus again
but yeah they're they're concerned about
changing we don't want to change the
narrative too much
sure number four uh the news last week
was that president trump will not be
attending
the inauguration which you know in every
sense to me
it seems like like it's probably for the
best
is it isn't it for the best is it isn't
it best for everybody involved
trump biden the country if trump just
isn't there
but cnn thinks it's disgusting they're
very offended by it
i think the no i know the real reason
why they're upset and i'll talk about
that in a second but
here it is the president already had as
a parting shot an alleged incitement to
a deadly riot
and now he will add one more 12 days
from now
by denying that step the presidents have
done since the mid 19th century
attending their successors inauguration
tell us the significance of this to his
legacy what remains of it
well he's actually a sore loser isn't it
gemini
you contrast what he said last night
and it just proves how false those words
were last night
in that in that video it was a friend
told me it looked like a hostage video
that you know he was forced he was
forced to make those statements and he
sent out tweets today that make it clear
he didn't really believe what he was
saying
uh and i think for him not to come as as
he
is an ultimate insult you know there are
a lot of people who are going to be glad
he's not there
uh because he would distract a lot of
attention it would be a lot about the
biden
trump dynamic on the on stage and we'll
be spared that at least
but nonetheless this is wrong um and
if we're going to heal the country we
have to trump has to play a part in that
and bring
his base around and to say we're going
to be part of the normal politics and
when we lose we lose but we'll try to
take it back next time i just
it would be so much better for the
country i think this is
you know he's just so insulting in so
many ways
and such a cry baby it's just disgusting
it's funny says crybaby at the end of
there after he just was crying for for
90 seconds
it's so disgusting it's so disappointing
i'm just so i'm so offended by
and he even acknowledges that it's
probably for the better
because that's exactly right what he
said if if trump is there
all we're going to hear about and all
they're going to cover is the dynamic
between the two and
all of the shots are going to be on
trump
it'll be biden's inauguration but it
would be all about trump because if
trump is there anyway it's always going
to be all about trump
um especially as far as the mass media
is concerned
so they say it's so this was the right
move
by trump and i can guarantee you it's
what it's also what by the way biden
probably prefers so what
why are they upset that he's not there
it's not because it's disgusting and
insulting
we all know it's for the best well the
answer is just that they want
they if he's not there then that gives
them less to talk about
less to cover they want that controversy
that's what they want it
trump being biden's inauguration by
itself
who cares who's going to tune in to
watch biden's inauguration
nobody gives a damn biden's inauguration
with trump there
now that's a ratings bonanza everybody's
going to
i would tune in just to see how that
plays out
so that's what they're that is what
they're upset about what they are
disgusted by
is that trump has just denied them the
ratings that they would have got
that's what this is all about all right
so
nfl playoffs this week as already
mentioned um some really great football
games
also something a little strange a little
different nickelodeon hosted its first
playoff game
um the idea was to get the kids into
football i guess so they put they put
the games on nickelodeon too
and or at least one of the games they
put on um saints and
and uh and bears game they put on
nickelodeon and they added new features
like virtual slime
and cartoon graphics and all kinds of
stuff and this is real they really did
this
so let's play we have some of the
footage here let's just play this
see what this looks like uh
yes exactly brees lost the football oh
it's brought down
another turnover
john jenkins in the bread basket bear
hugs it and the bears are in business
big celebration on the field now oh yeah
nate when you were back
uh playing football how did you come up
with the perfect touchdown dance what
did that feel like
i used to practice in the mirror the
night before the game said gabby
yep and then the cartoon slam okay so
that's what that looked like
and you had you know you had different
the announcers a little bit different um
they had a woman in the in the in the
announcing booth
nothing wrong with that um
but uh there was the nickelodeon thing
it actually wasn't yeah
i watched a little bit of that and i saw
i i sort of wanted to hate it but
i thought this is kind of cool i don't
know i'm i'll be okay with it
it's obnoxious but i'm fine with it my
real problem
if i'm looking for something to have a
problem with here it is uh my real
problem is
is with this the nickelodeon viewers you
know the kids watching
um they got to vote on their own mvp
candidate which they're calling the nvp
the nickelodeon's valuable player
and they gave it to mitch trubisky who's
the quarterback of the bears
the bears lost 21 to 9 in the game
scherbisky went 19 for 29 passing for
199 yards
one touchdown not terrible um especially
by his standards but is it mvp worthy
and this is the problem with kids today
first of all they don't know a damn
thing about football okay
my seven-year-old son voted for mitch
trubisky and i said to him
you obviously have no idea what the hell
you're talking about drew brees had 265
yards 70
completion right two touchdowns to qbr
of 107 and he won the game
and and you're going to vote for mitch
strubisky go to your room
you're grounded this is the problem with
kids first of all clueless about the
facts
second guided by emotions rather than
data and evidence
they felt sorry for trubisky so they
gave him the award
pitiful is what i say but anyway
congratulations to mitch trubisky this
is the only
this this is the only football related
honor he will ever win
and uh so i say maybe we should just let
him have his
day in the sun before we get to our
daily cancellation you know one thing
that historically i have struggled with
in my life is uh
not getting great sleep kind of insomnia
being very uncomfortable at night
and recently though um ever since i got
in my pillow and i've and i've
been working with my pillow that has not
been a problem with me i'm telling you
the best
sleep you'll ever get is with a my
pillow and it's great for me because i
sleep very soundly i sleep like a baby
um my wife you know it's it's a little
bit harder for her sometimes because
that means like if the kids are crying
in the middle of night
she's the one who wakes up and hears it
but i'm doing great because i'm
comfortable so
i can only endorse my pillow the thing
about my pillows their pillows don't go
flat you can wash and try them as many
times as you want
and they maintain their shape and best
of all they're made right here in the
usa
if you don't have a my pillow or you
know someone who doesn't have one now's
the time because for a limited time mike
is offering his premium my pillows
the ones that started it all you know
the the classic my pillows for his
lowest price ever you can get a queen
size premium my pillow
which is normally 69.98 for only 29.98
okay that's the deal it's 40 bucks in
savings over 50 off
uh and kings are only five bucks more
now is the time to buy if you want to
try out the my pillow see what
everyone's been talking about
then do it right now 29.98 for a queen
size
premium my pillow um and i can tell you
my
this is this is the truth i use a my
pillow every single night
and um it has solved all of my pillow
problems which i didn't even know i had
pillow problems
until i got a my pillow so go to
mypillow.com and click on the radio
listener square
um there you'll find not only this
amazing offer but also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream bed sheets the
my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets all great um
you can get those or you can call 800
651
1148 and use promo code daily wire
well something else to talk talk about
uh briefly and this is
obviously already spent the first part
of the show talking about this uh
censorship from big
tech the actions of big tech last week
made it very clear
that they will do everything they can to
silence opposing voices
um i mean remember they this is this is
beyond even maybe what what
some of us this is beyond some people's
worst nightmares for what would happen
you know this quickly
where where they're uh not only driving
people away from the big platforms
but then trying to take down the
platforms where the conservatives then
go and congregate like parlor
that's what they're doing now um we've
already told you
for us on our platform at dailywire.com
we've told you about our ambitious plans
with investigative news and
entertainment content
but with the actions of big tech last
week it's pretty clear that we can't
stop there
it's clear that we need to do a lot more
than that we have to take action to
build or buy
tech to protect ourselves from the
attack that's coming so that we can
continue to deliver new content to you
and we can also fight back
and so that we we all have this us and
you as the
as the audience we have this place to
come and congregate
um we're exploring all possibilities so
new data centers
payment gateways a lot more there's
there's tons that can be done
and our team has been working hard on
all of this i know they were up all
weekend working on this
but we can't do all that on our current
budget that's just the reality we need
more of your support
so just just to give you some of the
numbers here so that you understand
we're being totally transparent
there are 50 million of you that we
reach every single month in the first
phase we need one million members to
take on this fight
okay so 50 million of the people in our
audience we need to convert
you know a small fraction of that uh
into members
new york times is over seven million
paying subscribers wapo has
3 million subscribers uh hbo max is 13
million
netflix has 73 million so you see how
powerful they are
if you think all these companies need a
challenger then we need your membership
uh if you believe in what we've done so
far if you
like our content if you rely on it then
we need you to step up and help us win
because the other thing is you you you
know if you if you access our content
through facebook or youtube or twitter
or something like that
that's great but what we know is that
you you cannot rely
on those platforms to facilitate um us
coming together
that that's that might not happen for
very long you could get banned
we could get banned we all could get
banned at any moment
and that's why before that happens we
need to build up this platform to
everything that it needs to be
if you think your freedoms are at stake
and that the future of the country
depends on this fight then
i mean you're right now is your chance
to do something about it join daily wire
right now we don't know what they're
going to hit us with next
nobody saw really the last week coming
and it's not going to get better from
here so
that's why right now is the time to join
daily wire
to have a platform where we're not
relying on these big tech oligarchs
become a member at dailywire.com
subscribe
and tell all your friends do the same
again dailywire.com
subscribe let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so today exciting news for joe biden as
he's getting his first cancellation of
his term and his term hasn't even
started yet i expect there will be many
occasions to cancel biden
in the years ahead during the course of
the harris administration so
um i'll have to choose my spots a little
bit can't cancel them all unfortunately
but here's a spot definitely worth
choosing joe biden
delivered a speech this weekend
discussing his plans for coronavirus
relief
and he wants to save american small
businesses he said after spending now
he wants to save them after spending
months supporting the policies that are
destroying them
but here he is describing the plan and
how the plan will be implemented listen
focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no fault of their own
our priority will be black latino asian
and native american-owned small
businesses women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
okay so he says his priority will be
black latino asian native american and
women-owned businesses
not just his personal priority but the
priority of his administration
his government when um when helping
these businesses out
there's a term for this it's one we hear
a lot it's called
systemic racism if that term has any
meaning at all
then this must be it let's look at it
racism dictionary definition
prejudice discrimination or antagonism
directed against a person or people on
the basis of their particular
membership in a in a racial group that's
what this is
and it will be systemic in a literal
sense it will be discrimination
by the system now notice something here
he mentions black latino native american
women and asian business owners as the
priority groups
this is a problem because first of all
he said latino instead of la tinx
which proves that he's transphobic and
speaking of which
he didn't specifically mention trans
business owners as a priority
or gay business owners or bigendered
polysexual drag queen business owners
leaving me to assume that he hates all
those people and is literally hitler
what other explanation could there be
these are the rules now but more to the
point
the inclusion of asians is telling
because
asians do better than white people in
this country economically financially
their median household income is
something like twenty thousand dollars
higher
so this already is pretty good evidence
that white privilege is a myth
you know it's white privilege but the
people who do the best here aren't white
so that tears down that whole um house
of cards
it's also evidence that the
prioritization of non-whites in biden's
plan has nothing to
do with helping the disadvantaged
despite how it's being sold because
that's what they'll tell us they'll say
well these are just the groups it's not
about the race it's just that these are
the groups who
are most disadvantaged and so we're
trying to help them out well asians are
quite a bit less disadvantaged they are
more advantaged than whites and yet
they get the priority while white males
are left in the dust the real point for
biden and harris is simply to punish
white males that's the point
you might as well have saved himself
some time and some words especially as
it's
it obviously strains him to speak words
so he could have saved that trouble
and just said white males will get the
short end of the stick
or he could have said we will make sure
that white males don't get any help
because that's the point the point is
who they aren't helping
not who they are helping and this is
what we can expect in the years ahead
the the harris administration with biden
at its figure as its figurehead will be
the most racist in modern american
history the left is
long past hiding its racial bigotries
they blame white males for all the ills
in the world today and through history
and now they intend to punish the
villains and the problem is that most
conservatives as usual
have been too afraid for years to meet
this head-on and call it what it is
they have believed what the left has
told them that either anti-white racism
doesn't exist
or it's not a big deal or that somehow
it's racist in itself to call it out and
oppose it
but that was nonsense always was
he is and was we all know that that if
donald trump had ever given a speech
where he announced a plan to give relief
to business owners with priority to
white males especially can you imagine
that
the entire country would lose its mind
democrats would call for their third
impeachment
and there would be near unanimous
agreement that his plan was racist
nobody would disagree
it's no different here we never should
have allowed the left to pretend
that racism is somehow different when
directed at white males
but that's the lie that has cemented
itself into our culture
the cancer that has metastasized and
we're going to see how bad it gets
because they literally haven't even
gotten started yet
but for now biden is canceled
so i'm doing my part at least i don't
know what the rest of you can do but i
will at least cancel him repeatedly
hopefully that'll do something won't do
anything but
helps me vent anyway helps me
emotionally
uh and that's it we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by danny d'amico our
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
production assistant mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show all the
tech platforms ban trump and d
platform parlor the purge has begun
check it out on my show today
that is the ben shapiro show